j'ai pris je suis enfant j'adore
imaginer le futur dans les années 80
will et années 80 on imaginé l'an 2000
on imaginer des téléphones portables par
des téléphones sans le fil et de
téléphone on pouvait voir deux
correspondants on imagine est aussi
disposée comme ça deux films émissions
préférées pour éviter de demander à papa
et maman d'accéder au sacro-saint pozo
télévision du salon
aujourd'hui tout ça en là ça ferait
beaucoup rire mes enfants tout ça on
imaginait aussi avoir un ordinateur qui
répondra à toutes nos questions
on l'imaginé massif a rempli par par des
experts comme une énorme hanks eu un
petit loupé dit alors ça on l'a c'est
internet
c'est encore mieux pas remplies par les
espers est rempli par nous tous
internet c'est nous alors internet c'est
toute ma vie se trouve ça une invention
vraiment génial et j'en ai fait j'en ai
fait ma vie il ya verte rang j'ai fait
des études d'intelligence artificielle
on n'était pas nombreux à l'époque puis
j'ai participé à la construction à la
conception de plusieurs moteurs
d'applications sur internet que vous
avez probablement utilisé par exemple
pour voyager puis vit maintenant voilà
je suis prof à l'université où
j'enseigne ce plaisir de concevoir à mes
étudiants depuis quelques temps
j'entends de la planète internet des
remords oui des remords des remords des
concepteurs de facebook et de google
ils disent bon dieu qu'est ce qu'on a
fait
quel problème avec internet le premier
problème c'est que on a totalement
abandonné votre intimité internet
moi le premier il ya toute ma vie sur le
net
toutes mes opinions tout sans trop
d'intérêt qui sont dans les réseaux
sociaux ou dans les moteurs de recherche
il ya mes trajets via les applications
gps il ya mon rythme cardiaque quand je
fais un footing
il ya toutes mes correspondances
professionnel privé
ce stock absolument tout sur internet
effectivement ça fait un petit peu un
petit peu peur pour la première solution
tous supprimés c'est radical
bon je pense que enfin moi j'y crois pas
trop à cette solution puis je suis pas
prêt à abandonner ses outils géniaux
qu'on a nous on croit pas capable
absolue l'autre solution elle est un peu
plus raisonnée c'est de faire attention
de pros de protéger de donner les
crypter pour ça c'est dans les rangs
c'est dans l'air du temps pis ça vient
voilà par exemple qu'à une directive
européenne qui l'année prochaine va
imposer à tous les opérateurs sur
internet de protéger nos données et de
nous apporter le droit à l'oubli total
ainsi que la portabilité de nos données
pour passer d'un opérateur à un autre
un peu comme nos amis nos numéros de
téléphone
aujourd'hui c'est très bien ça hein
personnellement ça me fait un peu
souffrir de protéger nos données étaient
cryptées d'empêcher le tracking ce qui
fait ça fait sourire parce que quand
j'entends que la nsa l'agencé de
sécurité américaine health était à quai
par wikileaks sur essayé de protéger ses
données
alors j'entends aussi une autre solution
ce serait de vendre nos données bah oui
pourquoi pas pas des grands les grands
groupes ils vont massivement de nos des
personnels oui c'est comme ça qu'ils
gagnent leur vie ils les vendent ces
nouveaux produits et nous sommes une
mine d'or certains disent même que c'est
le pétrole de demain
personnellement je suis pas sûr que ce
soit une bonne idée de vendre son
intimité
je crois même que que dans nos sociétés
modernes
on a interdit la marchandisation de nos
corps on demande on interdit de vendre
des organes ont fait des dons voilà je
pense que demain
de la même façon il faudra avoir des
lois qui empêchent de vendre nos données
de vendre notre âme
alors comment fait on quel est le
problème
problème ce n'est pas les de protéger
ses données ou de les vendre
le problème c'est ce qu'on en fait des
données on va prendre à quelques
exemples simples comprendre ce que je
veux dire on va commencer par facebook
facebook que son utilité aujourd'hui
c'est c'est vous publiez des centaines
d'informations et puis pour que vous
avez pu se les voir donc on se retrouve
avec une masse d'informations possibles
sur vos murs qui est très important donc
l'eau l'algorithme donc le programme qui
fait tourner facebook c'est de filtrer
cette information pour le réduire pour
que ce soit lisible
cet algorithme c'est le edge ranque à
lui c'est son fonctionnement il est un
petit peu connu c'est à dire que l'on va
on va plutôt privilégier dans le filtre
l'affinité qu'il ya entre le lecteur et
le
l'auteur la réputation de votre
publication
est-ce qu'il ya beaucoup de jeunes est
ce que c'est une information qui est
récente et après il ya des choses un
petit peu plus floue voire un peu voilà
bah par exemple si on paie voilà si on
met de l'argent pour remonter voilà
c'est comme ça que facebook gagne de
l'argent et après il y avait des
paramètres encore beaucoup plus fous
beaucoup plus bas par exemple il ya des
états qui interdisent enfin qui
demandent des filtres pour sur le
terrorisme sur la violence sur la
pornographie et qui imaginent que la
chine ou d'autres pays on nous demandait
des trucs bien spéciaux 1 alors c'est ce
sucre
c'est ça qui fait le pitre qui skie ce
que vous voyez vous quand ça représente
à peine 10 % de ce qui est publié sur
facebook ce que vous voyez vous un donc
ça s'est passé ne sais pas ce que veut
le dire les concepteurs de facebook
quand lille 5-4 de ce qu'ils ont fait
c'est pas que ils ont construit un mot
un monstre incontrôlable
non le programme le substrat de facebook
il est incontrôlable
ce qu'ils disent c'est que ces quelques
personnes seulement qui contrôlent ce
filtre et et si demain
mark zuckerberg le patron de facebook et
si demain il décide de devenir président
des états unis
il a tout
toutes les ficelles pour manipuler
l'opinion parce qu'il sait tout de nous
donner tous deux 2 milliard
d'utilisateurs dans le monde pas rien
à passant à google google c'est
l'algorithme
il s'appelle le page rank prennent un
peu plus simple lui pour être en haut
dans google
il suffit de ça il suffit de voir des
pages qui sont pour une bonne réputation
c'est à dire que plus on pointe de liens
vers vous pouvez vous retrouver en haut
sur facebook plus plein d'autres
paramètres
alors moi je m'amuse beaucoup j'imagine
que les concepteurs de google s'amuse
beaucoup de voir les gens qui
travaillent dans le référencement
naturel qui essayent de découvrir
comment ça marche
j'imagine que en plus quand ils voient
que les autres et les référents seront
trouvées il s'amuse à changer les règles
pour jouer vous êtes très drôle désolé
et donc au bois le problème ce que
l'économie sur internet ça comme ça
représente ça représente une bonne
partie de l'économie mondiale ces 4000
milliards
donc aujourd'hui c'est cette tenue par
quasi une seule société call monopole et
donc il ya le choix de monter ou
descendre en fonction de paramètres
totalement opaque
un exemple un autre exemple beaucoup
plus français
l'application post bac apb qui fait
l'affectation des lycéens dans nos
universités ou dans les grandes écoles
on entendu beaucoup parler
cet été sur la scène bell bureaucratie
on adore se cacher derrière la
bureaucratie je pense dans tous les pays
mais en france en particulier parce que
c'est bien connu c'est à cause de l'apb
qu'il n'y a pas assez de place à
l'université que tout le monde n'a pas
eu sa place cet été c'est sûr alors
l'apb comme les autres c'est un
programme informatique
moi si je suis pas contre que demain des
algorithmes qui fasse nos démarches
administratives ou qui décident de chose
juridique de nos vies mois quelque part
je préfère quelquefois que ce soit un
algorithme qui gère ça puisque ils sont
pas influençable n'ont pas d'opinion ils
ont pas de compassion
ils ont édicté les règles qu'on leur a
donné par contre il milite je milite
pour que ces règles soient connus mythe
pour la transparence parce que direct
d'un orgue au rythme d'un programme
c'est comme les comme les lois on est
dit à l'assemblée nationale rien de plus
donc comme comme l'assurent nationale et
nationales faut que ces règles soient
connus c'est limite si l'internet de
demain que j'imagine comme ça et comment
on devient acteur de l'internet de
demain
je propose plusieurs niveaux d'action
pour nous tous le premier niveau
c'était des consom'acteurs acteurs alors
oui effectivement il faut que nous
fassions fassions attention à notre
participation sur les réseaux sociaux et
sur nos utilisateurs d'internet
continuer à faire attention à garder vos
jardins secrets et un réseau pour les
amis un réseau pour le professionnel
essayer chez dc les choses bien compacte
bien bien dans l'ordre bien isolé
faites attention aussi à à protéger vos
mots de passe ici essayez de ne pas vous
faire craquer ça c'est des petites
choses à faire et puis vous ferez le
choix d'une application
maintenant que vous savez un petit peu
comment ça marche et s'il allait vers
des outils ou on vous explique ou
l'algorithme est transparent
le deuxième niveau c'est celui de
citoyen acteur celui la politique du
juridique comme on le fait aujourd'hui
sur la sur les données privées sur la
confiance y alité des données privées il
faudra le faire sur les algues ont
imposé canal gorille dans le monde de la
sphère administrative ou dans la sphère
privée soit compréhensible explique
leslie pied ik ben haddou tous le
dernier niveau c'est au niveau warriors
vous incitent-elles venir des
programmeurs les enfants les ados on s'y
met c'est une filière où il ya du
travail
en plus on peut changer le monde non
alors moi j'adore parce que quand on on
peut programmer à partir de l'âge de 7
ans vous verriez des enfants de 7 ans
qui fonda decoding goûter qui est au
bout d'une heure ils vous programme des
jeux c'est impressionnant si vous n'êtes
plus un enfant vous pouvez vous mettre à
ocourt en ligne sont super bien fait il
a beaucoup n'hésitez pas puis j'ai envie
de dire à mes collègues informaticiens
programmeurs l6 mettions un peu
d'éthique on au programme
si nous faisions attention à comment
nous programmons comment nous inventons
les nouvelles applications de demain de
l'internet de demain si nous mettions de
la transparence dans ce que dans nos
algorithmes serait beaucoup nous pour
l'internet de demain et pour finir
sauf que le prenais programmés soit
peut-être c'est vous qui serait
programmée merci